est-ce que tu crois que même on te
dominant le plus possible tu aurais du
mal à essayer de te faire abstraction de
tout ça et quand on t'ennuie comme ça de
faire comme si de rien n'était je crois
que tu as pas vraiment essayé
je m'appelle Sarah j'ai 12 ans
j'habite à Strasbourg et à l'école et
dans la rue on mettra des saltêtes et de
caméléons et je trouve que c'est injuste
ça a commencé quand je suis arrivé au
collège
des garçons de 5e
et 5e ou Traité de sa tête puis ça a
duré toute l'année et puis
en 5e il y a un garçon qui
est venu dans ma classe et qui a
commencé de me traiter de caméléon
tu fais pas un peu tu les provoques pas
un peu les autres de temps en temps
non
je les connaissais pas ils ont commencé
je les ai jamais provoqué
et tu arrives pas à comprendre pourquoi
on a commencé à te traiter de sale tête
de pas les écouter c'est plus fort que
moi j'arrive pas je
et puis je peux vous raconter l'histoire
qu'est-ce que bon je en cours je suis
pas très très bonne et on a fait appel
avec la 5e 2 les garçons bon ils ont
perdu contre les garçons et les filles
il y avait juste un garçon après moi
avant moi il m'a donné le relais et j'ai
pas couru assez vite et les filles ont
perdu ça fait que la cinquième lieu a
gagné et après les tout le monde a tout
remis sur mon dos c'est à cause de moi
qu'on avait perdu la cour
et mon il y a une fille qui n'est pas du
tout belle qui est un peu un peu assez
effronté et qui m'a dit caméléon qui a
dit aussi à cause de toi et tout alors
je dis mais pourquoi ça sera à cause de
moi toi aussi tu étais dans la course
elle a pas voulu ils ont pas voulu
m'écouter ils ont dit que c'était à
cause de moi et après je j'avais fait
une le haricoter ils vont pas voulu
alors
dans les discussions à la maison alors
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui se dit sur
ce problème
tes parents ils disent que c'est grave
ou pas grave pour l'instant c'est pas
grave
et toi tu es sûr que c'est vraiment
c'est à côté c'est peut-être grave de
traiter quelqu'un qu'on se donne de
traiter quelqu'un qu'on ne connaissait
pas et de lui dire de lui dire sa tête
comme ça parce qu'on alors comme il me
voit il me disent que ils ont envie de
vomir des trucs comme ça
mais non et le garçon qui t'a traité de
caméléon il y a une tête de commande
tout à l'heure il était là il est il
prend le même chemin que moi mais il est
peut-être que c'est parce que eux ils
sont pas beaux qui veulent me traiter de
tous les noms faut pas avouer que eux
ils sont pas beaux c'est surtout les
garçons qui tombent
et toi tu es comment avec les garçons
est-ce que tu as l'impression d'être par
rapport aux autres enfants de l'école
d'être un cas spécial et unique
moi je
qu'est-ce que tu as juste
à dire que on pourrait être je sais pas
jaune violet de toutes les couleurs on
peut on peut peut-être avoir une tête de
Gorée ou des trucs comme ça mais on est
toujours un humain alors ça me ça
m'énerve parce que je suis je suis
quelqu'un comme tous les autres
bien oui je suis quelqu'un comme tous
les autres et je vois pas pourquoi on
traiterait différemment qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette façon de se comporter
envers un être humain alors en gros
c'est un petit peu ça tu as
revendication ça
tu es toujours d'accord avec tout ce que
tu as dit dans le reportage que nous
venons de voir les choses n'ont pas
changé à l'école ni rien à évoluer non
rien mais ça n'a pas empiré non plus on
tombe pas plus qu'avant
veux-tu que je te présente toutes les
personnes qui sont autour de nous disons
pour celles qui est une connaîtrais pas
parce qu'il y en a déjà plusieurs que tu
connais bien je crois que ta maman est
avec nous sur le plateau aujourd'hui
bonjour madame bienvenue vous êtes
l'avocate de votre fille évidemment vous
avez été un petit peu témoin certaines
scènes ou pas témoin mais surtout
interpellé par ma fille parce que ça
avait pris effectivement avoir un moment
des proportions insupportables pour elle
et ça donnait bon ben des repas
uniquement concentrés sur ce problème de
de caméléon de sa tête alors je dois
dire que il y avait des moments où j'en
avais marre ça c'est sûr
on l'a fait avant c'est à dire qu'on a
essayé de dire que c'était pas grave et
de trouver avec Sarah des moyens un
petit peu de se défendre Bernadette
Crozet vous êtes psychologue
psychanalyste c'est bien cela alors à ma
gauche maintenant il y a Jean-Paul que
je vous présente salut Jean-Paul alors
tu fais partie des garçons qui qui ne
s'entendent pas très très bien avec
Sarah je vous présente Ghislaine Verget
bonjour bonjour vous êtes professeur oui
je suis professeur professeur de lettres
de lettres dans quel état dans un
collège donc je connais bien les enfants
de l'âge de Sarah je m'appelle Stéphane
j'ai 13 ans
et
je la traitée aussi de caméléon alors
et ça ton attitude a changé maintenant
ben non je lui ai plus dit depuis la
dernière fois donc ton attitude a changé
si tu le faisais et tu le fais plus
c'est que tu as changé d'idées oui tu le
fais plus et tu as décidé d'arrêter de
le faire bon ben tu vas nous expliquer
pourquoi tant d'abord la parole à tes
petites camarades je m'appelle
j'ai 13 ans je suis dans la classe de
Sarah puis je reste toujours avec elle
avec Valérie
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'elles étaient les
motivations qui faisaient que tu étais
contre il y a quelques temps puisque
aujourd'hui tu as un petit peu changé
d'attitude je sais pas il y avait un
garçon qui avait commencé à traiter de
caméléon et moi je disais pas ça
vraiment méchamment je disais pour
rigoler
avec le temps ça devine c'est devenu
trop difficile pour toi de le supporter
comme si en sixième on ne la connais pas
vous arrivez tous en sixième de
d'horizon différents vous ne vous
connaissez pas le mon Dieu on dit sale
tête à quelqu'un mais avec le temps on
devrait apprendre à connaître les gens
c'est peut-être ce que tu demandais
est-ce que ça n'est pas ça ton problème
ben si j'aurais bien aimé qu'il me
connaissent un peu plus qui
voyait un peu que
que je suis pas vraiment
quel que je suis pas quelqu'un
d'ailleurs voilà alors au départ tu as
eu un petit problème avec des garçons de
la classe il y a eu des petits heures il
y a eu quelque chose entre vous une
heure d'abord il n'était pas dans ma
classe oui et mais il y a rien eu rien
du tout donc toi tu ne sais pas tu ne
comprends pas l'origine de ce problème
pas vraiment et elle m'a demandé un jour
mais enfin maman qu'est-ce que c'est
caméléon et quand je lui ai expliqué ça
a été vraiment très douloureux pour elle
parce que je dis douloureux parce que là
elle s'est demandé pour quelle raison on
lui avait attribué ce nom-là et pas
l'autre d'autant qu'elle est assez
fonceuse assez sûr de ce qu'elle dit
elle ne comme ça elle ne se confond pas
vraiment avec avec le milieu environnant
c'est peut-être un peu gênant d'ailleurs
ça c'est ce que j'ai tenté de lui faire
comprendre que peut-être sa façon
je tiens pas du tout à ce qu'elle soit
caméléon mais elle est comme elle est
elle était elle est suffisamment
dynamique et peut-être un petit peu
agressif quelquefois dans la façon
qu'elle a de parler
je ne sais pas du tout comment elle est
en classe parce que je n'y vais pas
c'est sa vie elle se connaît d'une
certaine manière et le fait qu'on lui
attribue caméléon avec ce cette espèce
de
les arts qui changent de peau qui change
de couleur ça ne lui a vraiment pas plus
est-ce que tu te souviens comment ça a
débuté ces histoires et la prof de
biologie elle nous a montré un criquet
alors un copain à moi qui était aussi
assez tout près à côté de moi il m'a
fait regarde sa râle doit bien mais ça
parce que les caméléons ça alors alors
ça a donné une petite idée comme ça et
vers midi comme ça après on était sorti
alors là on a une petite dispute moyenne
en sortant comme ça alors là je commence
à l'appeler caméléon et ça ça continue
comme ça quelques jours après il y en a
il y en a plusieurs qui ont entendu
comme ça alors ils ont aussi commencé
sur le à surnommer Sarah de caméléon
c'est vrai que ça pose la question vous
me disiez aussi de
bon de la du gras ou du pas grave pour
un enfant et le c'est pas grave donc il
a été question dans le petit reportage
on mesure pas bien c'est vrai
l'importance que ça peut avoir certains
mots c'est nous qui tue ces mots qui
font qui font mal et en fait on a
l'impression que là il y a une
succession d'événements de mots la
caméléon qui se rajoute à la salade
caméléon tout seul effectivement c'est
drôle hein mais caméléon après la salete
après et puis tout dépend avec quel ton
avec le Son alors c'est ce que je
voulais dire aussi mais quand vous
disiez ça et quand toi tu continues à
dire ça est-ce que c'était méchant
est-ce que c'était vraiment dans le but
de lui faire du mal pour vraiment
l'embêter ou disons d'abord quand en
disant ça c'était juste pour une petite
moquerie comme ça mais je pensais pas
que ça allait faire tout un drame comme
ça il peut y avoir quand même faut pas
se méprendre parmi dans une école parmi
des jeunes de véritables histoires de
méchanceté ça ça existe aussi puisqu'on
sait que les jeunes entre eux
extrêmement dures extrêmement à parler
de groupe de différents groupes et ça ça
existe vraiment les différents groupes
ce qui est gênant dans ton affaire ça
rend en fait c'est que je crois que tous
les groupes qui existent dans la classe
ont repris caméléon au sale tête je
crois que tout le monde a repris cela
dans la classe il y avait pas ceux qui
me traitent de sa tête ne sont pas dans
la même classe que moi voilà alors il y
a eu des grosses différences voilà mais
bien sûr
de la récréation et puis
on était assez au bon et puis Sarah et
moi il Valérie et puis il y avait des un
groupe de garçons et commencer ils
étaient tout autour de nous et puis il
commence à dire il insulté il dit sale
tête et tout et Sarah c'est plus quoi
faire et puis tu es énervé ça s'est
inscrit tout de suite comme ça chez
Sarah et en fait c'est ça qui est
marchait
c'est ça qui a fait qu'en fait ça a été
repris parce que comme vous disiez aussi
Sarah ne sait plus où se mettre quand on
la traite comme ça ça provoque tellement
des faits qu'en fait plutôt que de dans
cette mon méchanceté aussi qui a été
évoquée à cette rivalité dans ces
systèmes un peu plannings comme ça et
bien c'est repris ses repris parce que
ça marche et c'est comme s'il fallait
bien qu'il y en ait quelques-uns qui
soient bouc émissaires pour aussi que
les autres puissent être préservés de
cette position là le mot le plus grave
c'est ça la tête ou c'est caméléon que
je sais ce que pourquoi il me traitait
de caméléon je pense que c'est sa tête
donc peut-être je ne serai jamais là
vous comprenez je crois que ça le tête
ici avec ce qu'elle a dit dans son
reportage ça me semble plus moi ça me
semble aussi plus important je vais te
dire j'aimerais pas du tout non plus que
vous dit ça vous aimeriez non pas
vraiment
tu n'as pas l'impression Sarah je te
pose la question comme je le pense que
ça pourrait être une espèce de racisme
voilà vous voilà je sais pas vraiment
mais le garçon qui me traite maintenant
de sale tête un jour à traiter une
copine à moi qui qui est café au lait
qui est noir la traiter de négresse et
ça lui a fait beaucoup de peine
j'imagine moi si on me traitait de ça
juive moi ça me ferait de la peine et je
demande et je n'accepterai pas je n'ai
jamais traité quelqu'un de de ça le de
ça quelque chose voilà tu n'avais
absolument pas dit dans le reportage que
tu étais juge non je ne l'ai pas dit tu
l'avais pas dit et pourtant tu devais
essayer de résumer toute ta situation
alors que tu es déjà consciente que ça
peut peut-être être un des phénomènes je
pense pas vraiment parce que ils ne
savent pas que je suis juive je pense
pas qu'ils savent que je suis juive mais
peut-être comme ma mère a dit que ça
doit être quelque chose de peut-être
jalousie parce que mon père est dans
l'école il est délégués de classe et
enfin délégué parental et je pense que
c'est la jalousie qui les amène à faire
ça moi je crois que c'est possible
racisme je dirais non
j'ai tenté de le penser je me suis posé
la question et je pense que si ça avait
été du racisme alors Sarah on aurait été
vraiment vraiment très malade parce que
les choses sont dites alors avec
beaucoup plus de violences
quand l'embête là elle fait tout un
cirque alors c'est pour ça que je crois
aussi que pour les autres garçons alors
ça les amuse alors ça il continue à les
la maltraiter comme ça alors c'est pour
ça ce qui a fait tout un cirque ouais
elle est je sais pas Audrey qu'elle
danse elle court tout elle tape dessus
est-ce que tu crois que même en te
dominant le plus possible tu aurais du
mal à essayer de te faire abstraction de
tout ça et quand on t'ennuie comme ça de
faire comme si de rien n'était
je crois que tu as pas vraiment essayé
comme ça ben si j'essayerai je veux bien
essayer mais c'est a eux aussi de se
dominer parce que
dans la dans la rue il me voit il me ils
ont pas à me traiter comme ça maman
quand j'ai vu le reportage là il y a
quelques jours pour la première fois je
te connaissais pas j'avais jamais
entendu parler de ton histoire j'ai dit
à Agnès Vincent je dis tiens elle a un
faisard de Michael Jackson
on m'a déjà dit
pas complètement idiot et à leur compte
si on dit ça qu'est-ce que ça j'aime pas
Jackson alors ça me met pas en colère
parce que parce que c'est quelque chose
que tu as déjà remarqué puis que ça a
pas de connotation péjorative bon mais
ressemblait que Jackson
n'a plus envie d'être Michael Jackson ni
graisse de Monaco ou non Stéphanie
elle a envie d'être ça et je crois que
c'est ça que vous avez envie de faire
entendre et vous avez fait certainement
entendre aujourd'hui tu as l'impression
quand même à la fin de l'émission que ça
dédramatisé un petit peu maintenant que
j'ai appris pourquoi on m'appeler de
camelos
[Musique]